we begin today with that major update in
our nation's efforts to vaccinate more
americans
the cdc and the fda are now recommending
a pause in the use of the johnson and
johnson vaccine
over concerns about potentially
dangerous blood clots
for some perspective they report issues
among six people
out of nearly seven million doses
administered johnson johnson says there
is no clear link yet
between the shot and the blood clots but
doctors do want to further investigate
hector mejia is live now with more on
this so hector has our
state stopped using that vaccine
yeah while none of the six rare cases
are in nevada the state is no longer
using the johnson and johnson vaccine
until we learn more
that's major news for local vaccination
sites including the las vegas convention
center here
where today's appointments for the j and
j shot were canceled
we actually found a sign at the front
entrance advising people
no johnson and johnson here the southern
nevada health district says it's
following
federal recommendations to pause the use
of this particular vaccine
officials stress that the blood clot
reactions appear to be
extremely rare six known cases in the
nation
none of them here in nevada officials
say they were all reported among women
between the ages of 18
and 48 their symptoms occurred six to 13
days after getting the vaccine
out here at the convention center
there's talk about how this
will impact public confidence
i've had some anxiety over getting the
shot not getting the shot
i'm just glad i didn't get that one i
mean i know one person that got it she
seems to be
okay i'm sure there'll be another one
coming right behind it
or they'll fix it or you know they'll
get to the bottom of it
our health district says it has
administered about 47
000 shots of the johnson and johnson if
you got it within three weeks and
develop severe headache
abdominal leg pain or shortness of
breath they recommend for you to contact
your doctor
now the health district also says that
the impact in terms of appointments for
today
is minimal again federal pause is being
done quote out of an abundance
of caution and the cdc will reconvene
tomorrow
and reassess that recommendation
reporting live outside the las vegas
convention center hector mejia
8 news now